[Musik]
in Hameln in Niedersachsen hat sich die
Stadt für Grundstückseinfahrten eine
sonder nutzungsgebührensatzung einfallen
lassen wer eine zubreite Zufahrt zu
seinem Grundstück hat soll eine extra
Gebühr zahlen Eigentümer von Bauernhöfen
mit entsprechend breiten Einfahrten
müssen dann dafür schnell mal ein paar
hundert Euro brechen ja für ja
ich dachte das ist ein schlechter Scherz
als ich davon das erste Mal erfahren
habe das war also demnächst Eintritt
zahlen um aufs eigene Grundstück zu
kommen das würden für mich wenn ich
alles so ließe wie es jetzt ist 565 €
pro Jahr bedeuten der Hof der steht
schon seit 1842 hier und jetzt auf
einmal 2023 möchte die Stadt für was
kassieren was eigentlich schon immer da
ist
dezember 2022 beschließt die Stadt
Hameln die jährliche
Sondernutzungsgebühr für zubreite zu
fahren seit dem gilt die Einfahrt bei
ein Familienhäusern darf maximal drei
Meter breit sein bei Gewerbegrundstücken
sind es sechs Meter jeder Meter mehr
kostet 15 € wer mehr als eine Einfahrt
hat zahlt zusätzlich 50 € pro Zufahrt
lustig Mieter für Landwirt wolfgang
bendite hat das absurd teure Folgen für
sein Traktor samt Anhänger braucht der
Breite Einfahrten sechs Meter reichen da
nicht denn sein Hof liegt an einer
absoluten Engstelle zahlen solle jetzt
insgesamt mehr als 700 € jährlich
viele Gewerbetreibende fühlen sich
abkassiert
also es kommt ja auch keine
Gegenleistung davor es ist ja ein
Ist-Zustand was seit Jahrhunderten ist
es ist ja nicht ein Sache die wo wir ein
Vorteil haben und da was für bezahlen
müssen dass man willkürlich eine
steuererfinden kann damit Anwohner auf
ihre Grundstücke fahren dürfen ich kann
sowas kann man nicht erwarten so was ist
dermaßen abstrus das gibt es nicht die
Stadt Hameln teilt uns mit die
Einführung der Sondernutzungsgebühr sei
das Ergebnis einer intensiven Abwägung
unverhältnismäßig breite Zufahrten
bedeuten eine Beeinträchtigung des
Gemeingebrauchs es werden also die
Interessen der Öffentlichkeit in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen aber in der
täglichen Praxis sind die privaten
Einfahrten entlang der engen Straßen bei
Gegenverkehr auch dringend benötigte
Ausweichflächen es ist auf keinen Fall
eine Sondernutzung sondern seit
Jahrhunderten wird es
traditionsmäßig hier so betrieben dass
sie Landwirtschaft eben breite
Einfahrten hat und nutzt das sind für
mich nur scheinbegründungen man muss was
finden um das jetzt durchzusetzen dass
man diese Gebühr erheben möchte aber die
Stadt Hameln bleibt entweder zahlen die
Eigentümer oder Mauern sich ihre
historischen Einfahrten demnächst zu